manoeuvrer une moissonneuse batteuse
dans un champ de blé entourée d'arbres 1
voici une image encore très inhabituel
mais cette expérimentation menée depuis
six ans dans le sud ouest de la france
commencent à franchir la loire et
pourrait modifier à terme le paysage des
plaines céréalières de la bourse
dans le nord du loiret le vent est un
adversaire redoutable
rien ou presque ne lui barre la route
ce qu'on avait mis comme essence et
pourquoi la sur ton projet et bien en
fait on a mis quatre cents à rouen à peu
près d'une quinzaine d'espèces
différentes pour faire des armes de haut
jet en fait le bois plus tard trois
lignes de plantation de 600 m de l'an
espacées de plus de 70 mètres et où
cohabitent une douzaine d'espèces
différentes pour l'exploitation de
vincent vanier 125 hectares de céréales
au total c'est une révolution qui est en
marche depuis mars 2020 donc en fait il
ya des noyers des poiriers des pommiers
ça ça pousse assez vite
enfin chez nous en tout cas dans le
terroir l'aspect environnemental
m'intéresse aussi puisque avec il ya des
bandes enherbées donc au sol plus les
arbres qui vont pousser on va avoir une
certaine végétation des insectes des
auxiliaires pour les cultures
donc ça va pas être un frein pour la
culture ça va plutôt être un petit boost
pour essayer d'utiliser moins de
produits phyto donc ça c'est la théorie
j'espère que j'y arriverai vraiment
d'après m
ne croit vraiment et toi tu as une
petite retouche à faire si vincent
vanier s'est lancé dans ce projet c'est
grâce aux conseils avisés d'un expert en
agroforesterie un ingénieur agronome
spécialiste de l'agro écologie
agriculture et environnement sont de
plus en plus liés et l'agroforesterie
est une pratique vertueuse mais aussi
économiquement attractive aujourd'hui on
sait de par les travaux de recherche
qu'il ya vraiment un intérêt des arbres
ou les arbres de par leur système
racinaire qui est profond puis s'en va
les chercher l'eau et surtout les
éléments minéraux profondeur et qui vont
remonter en surface on a une
complémentarité ce qui permet d'avoir
une productivité 1,4 fois plus important
quand on a des armes associées aux
cultures dont 15 à 20 ans ces arbres
apporteront un complément de revenus en
vendant le bois ou en commercialisant
les fruits ils seront aussi un rempart
efficace contre le vent et surtout
contre les effets du réchauffement
climatique
[Musique]